with the
road to athens taking the stronger by
science world by storm everybody's
crazy about it uh there's a lot of
questions about cardio these days so
someone asked me is high intensity
interval training better than low or
moderate intensity steady state for uh
for body composition purposes so looking
at different approaches to cardio high
intensity interval intervals versus
steady state exercise
and also what are some good interval
training protocols and how do you gauge
intensity for those protocols
so uh i had a very recent article in
mass that was about this there was a
meta-analysis by james steele and
colleagues and james is very very good
at doing research so highly recommend
his work
they looked at a big old group of
studies comparing steady state versus
interval type training they were
specifically looking at changes in fat
mass and fat-free mass so looking at
body composition
and what they found was no meaningful
difference in terms of fat loss or gains
in fat free mass so fairly modest effect
for both outcomes
in both cases they lost
about a quarter of a kilogram of fat and
gained like a tenth of a kilogram of fat
free mass
which is an important point so first of
all
cardio or endurance type exercise it's
great for a lot of things
but its independent effects
on weight loss really are not that big
so
a lot of times some people say i'm going
to take up running as an independent
standalone fat loss
endeavor
and
in many cases you know you might find
that you have really really positive
impacts on your health really great
impacts on appetite regulation things
like that but you know as a standalone
fat loss
intervention
probably leaves a little bit to be
desired doesn't mean it's not great for
your health and well-being but if fat
loss and weight loss truly are the goal
you probably want to do a mixture of
doing some additional physical activity
whether it's cardio or otherwise and
then adding in a a dietary component of
some type
anyway
it's important to recognize with this
meta-analysis
this was
only one of the studies in the
meta-analysis included resistance
training so that obviously is a
limitation considering that most of our
listeners
do a lot of resistance training
so the question is would the
analysis would it have turned out way
different if if resistance training were
uh included in a lot of these individual
studies i would argue probably not um
you know the the interference effect is
usually where people start getting
really focused when you talk about
combining cardio with resistance
training
multiple meta-analyses now have shown
that the interference effect is
pretty minimal for strength
and
very minimal for hypertrophy as long as
your resistance training and your
endurance training component are being
managed effectively like if you really
wanted to
you could use the interference effect to
mess up your gains but you'd have to be
trying pretty hard you'd have to be
doing a lot of things poorly to make
that work in most cases or just already
be at a really really high level in one
of the two pursuits correct yeah yeah
but but in most cases uh adding a little
bit of cardio or endurance training into
uh your lifting program
very unlikely to have a catastrophic
effect on your strengths and and even
less likely when it comes to body
composition hypertrophy
uh now my favorite hit protocols that i
like to do if you choose to go that
route um you could take one approach
that would probably fall under the
umbrella of sprint interval training and
the distinction between high intensity
interval training and sprint interval
training is pretty straightforward the
sprint stuff is all out it's maximal
intensity so
i do a type of sprint interval training
every now and then where i'll do 30
seconds
all out you know rpe 10 maximal
intensity and then i'll spend 90 seconds
below the kind i forget what the what
the term is but in in grad school they
mentioned like the conversation
threshold basically an intensity of
endurance type exercise where you could
still hold a pretty comfortable
conversation while doing it right so
it's i don't know how to convert that to
a specific rpe but
pretty chill pretty light you're
basically using 90 seconds to recover
and then you're right back into another
30 second sprint so i'll do that for 10
or 15 sprints in whatever modality you
choose cycling running swimming whatever
the case may be
i also like a high intensity interval
training protocol that's very
straightforward it's just one minute on
one minute off
the high intensity part of it i try to
do it an rpe of like nine or ten so like
the the way i would i would frame that
is if i'm doing it on a treadmill
by the end of that minute i'm like man
it's kind of
kind of drifting toward the back of the
treadmill a little bit you know it's
it's tough you you feel like you're
really at that nine or 10 level with the
rpe out of 10 obviously and then again
the one minute recovery
i'll either rest entirely or i'll just
do some light stuff below that
conversational threshold where i could
easily hold a conversation while i'm
doing it another less intense protocol
i'll do is is quite similar but i'll do
two minutes on and two minutes off and
with that i knock the rpe down a little
bit to like an eight to maybe like a
nine and a half so not knocking the
intensity down a little bit but
obviously doubling the duration of the
the high intensity interval there uh and
if i do that i might only do like half
the round so instead of doing ten one
minute high interval bouts i'll do like
five two minute high interval bouts and
like i said the the modality is not
critical uh cycling swimming rowing
running paddling whatever you want to do
you just want to make sure you find a
safe way to do it so you don't want to
throw yourself off the back of a
treadmill you don't want to be in a
precarious position where you like
fatigue yourself swimming in open water
obviously that would be dangerous if
you're not a strong swimmer but
yeah a lot of ways to do it and high
intensity interval training is you know
a very viable way to uh to get some of
the benefits of aerobic exercise or or
cardio type or endurance type exercise
um
as long as you're not doing it so much
with such high intensity that you are
just completely wiped out for your
lifting sessions you should be fine but
that is something to keep an eye on
obviously and then finally the biggest
caveat is i answered this question
specifically within the context of body
composition
if you're adding some type of endurance
training
for reasons that go beyond body
composition or cardiovascular health or
thing cardio metabolic health things
like that if you're trying to add in
endurance type exercise to
cultivate a specific physiological
capacity if you're doing it for a
specific performance reason
it's a completely different answer
obviously when you're doing that
you need to make sure that you are
tailoring your endurance type exercise
to really target the key energy systems
that you're trying to develop um so that
would be a completely different scenario
where you would have to really sort out
the details with your intensity your
duration your modality but if you're
just doing it for general health and
well-being or to burn a couple extra
calories
you know things of that nature really
not critical whether you pick one or the
other makes sense to me